Before a world of Heroes
and villains
one power ruled it all Black Adam
he's been asleep for 5 000 years
we're here to negotiate your
peaceful surrender I'm not peaceful
nor do I Surrender
my powers are not a gift
but a curse
born out of rage
You have two choices. You can be the destroyer of this world. Or you can be, it's savior.
It's his darkness, that lets him to do what heroes cannot.
The battle, you're meant to fight is upon us
there's no one on this planet that can stop me
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my new Black Adam trailer video they released a
Black Adam Justice League trailer there's a whole
bunch of footage we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel the movie's coming out
really soon I'll be doing videos for it like I do
for all the other big movies be sure to subscribe
to get them I'll do a giveaway for movie tickets
when we get a little bit closer too obviously
this new trailer is a big black Adam versus the
Justice League typo trailer like they're heavily
leaning on the association between the Black Adam
character in the Justice League four important
reasons that I'll explain some of you have been
thinking about this since the Black Adam movie was
announced but the other funny thing you may have
seen that just happened is when they released
the promo they actually took down the official
promo changed it just a little bit like made a
new edit and then re-uploaded it the rock even
posted corrected so when he says corrected what it
means is the original version of the promo had a
scene from the Joss Whedon version of the Justice
League movie and they just reposted one without it
the footage that they removed was basically like
a scene of the Joss Whedon version of Steppenwolf
swinging his ax and I guess people got crazy about
it I actually did not see people come complaining
about it I only saw after they re-uploaded the new
one it actually took me a little while to find out
what had happened like wait a minute why are they
re-uploading it what was wrong with the first one
turns out there was a whole bunch of theatrical
Justice League footage in it that people just
really did not like they basically just clipped
that out and then re-uploaded it Warner Brothers
said something weird about not using Snyder cut
footage in a lot of their current movies like
that's the reason why you don't see a lot of
Snyder cut stuff inside actual upcoming movies
a lot of the movies reference other movies like
yagadas Wonder Woman actually film new scenes
for Shazam Fury the Gods like she's in that movie
pretty good amount too and I think the main reason
why they don't use a lot of Snyder cut footage in
their promos particularly is because of financial
reasons I think it has something to do with the
contracts between the two different versions of
Justice League and it's just easier for them
on a corporate level to not address like just
step around the problem but the other funny thing
that they do during this Justice League promo is
that they didn't include footage of the actual
Joker even though they're referencing him like
they included footage of Harley Quinn blowing
up ace chemicals which which was meant to be
her blowing up the Joker's hideout in the birds of
prey movie like it was meant to be a joker scene
without the actual Joker because it was meant to
be Jared Leto's Joker and I think the reason why
they did that is because they're not totally sure
what they're gonna do with the new DC EU version
The Joker like it sounds like they don't want to
bring Jared Leto back as dceu Joker so they're
gonna have to recast at some point and they're
just not ready to do that yet because Joaquin
Phoenix is Joker the new Todd Phillips Joker
sequel is probably going to blow up just like
the first one and the funny thing about that is
that it's meant to be in its own little Universe
the Todd Phillips has gotten so powerful because
his movies have been so successful in the first
Joker movie was so successful he and Joaquin
Phoenix got crazy contracts for the sequel so
basically they become so powerful that Warner
Brothers can't tell them you have to make him
inside the dceu like he won't cross over unless
Todd Phillips wants him to cross over it's the
same kind of thing with Matt Reeves version of
the Batman the Robert Pattinson Batman he wants
it to be like his own separate little universe
so they're kind of protecting him even though
they just had all this crazy corporate level
stuff happening like all the debacle with the
Batgirl movie but the other big reason why they
released a Black Adam versus the Justice League
type of trailer for the movie for the Black Adam
movie is because currently the rock is pitching a
Black Adam versus the Justice League movie which I
talked about previously but now we just learned a
little bit more about it when they first announced
the movie The Rock was making all these references
to Black Adam fighting a version of Henry cavill's
Superman like he wanted to get a version of that
movie going but just because of the way things
were working in the past couple of years it
couldn't be the first movie that's why Sabaka is
probably the villain of this first movie instead
of it just being Superman because that would have
been a pretty awesome movie but during one of the
first promos they released for the actual movie
he literally put the Justice League on notice
like in the promo he specifically called them out
like the hierarchy of the DC EU is going to change
everybody's been posting memes about that line but
before I go I want you guys to help me out with
something it's something that's pretty important
I need you guys to help me get a message out to uh
to some of the other ones some of the
other DC superheroes let's let Flash Shazam
Aquaman Wonder Woman Batman and Superman let's let
them know something things will never be the same
because the hierarchy of power in
the DC Universe is about to change
the funny thing about that is that people are
just like why didn't he mention cyborg what's
going on with cyborg isn't he part of this
too who knows what's going on with that but
the reason why he's doing that is because he's
trying to get interest in a Black Adam versus
the Justice League movie at DC recently reports
have been calling it a Black Adam versus the
Justice League versus Suicide Squad it's sort
of like a three-way Mexican standoff where like
each three separate forces even though Black Adam
technically doesn't have a team with him like it's
Black Adam by himself were all three of those
different forces in the dceu kind of converge
and go on each other it sounds like it'll take
him a while to figure out what that's going to
be eventually and it probably will not be the next
Black Adam movie that'd be like the third or the
fourth movie that they work up to but that's the
main reason why you're seeing the rock talk about
the Justice League so much even though they're
introducing the Justice Society during this movie
we'll also probably see spin-offs for the Justice
Society at some point in the future too though
the whole Arc of the Black Adam movie is the
Justice Society convincing him to help them and
what'll probably happen at the end of this first
movie is that he will wind up defeating subak in
the then just like in the comics the next thing
he'll do is just take over a conduct and Rule it
with an Iron Fist and just kick out everybody
he doesn't like usually he just Minds his own
business and conduct ruling over his own people
like he doesn't get involved in international
Affairs unless it involves some larger magical
problem that potentially threatens conduct that
does wind up happening in the plot line that they
tease in the first shazam movie post credit scene
with Mr Mind the whole idea is that he wants to
use Dr Savannah to take over the magic lands the
Seven Realms of magic which are sort of like an
alternate Dimension this like pure magic if you
were able to do that he become god tier powerful
and threaten all of reality basically Black Adam
wound up getting involved in that comic book Arc
so it sounds like they'll do that for the third
shazam movie like they'll pay off that post
credit scene and Black Adam will get involved
in that and that'll be your big black Adam versus
Shazam crossover but early prediction unless they
just completely go in a left direction and do
something completely different what they'll do
is at the end of that Black Adam Shazam crossover
movie where they deal with Mr Mind in the Seven
Realms of magic is that they'll be some larger
consequences that will affect the main Earth then
the Justice League will get involved and that's
what you'll see Black Adam vs Justice League but
I think the whole Arc of that would be similar
to The Arc of this first Black Adam movie where
like the Justice Society comes to try and win him
over please help us we know you don't like us but
we need you to stop some greater threat only this
time it'll be Superman being the one to do that
like Superman fights into a standstill and while
he's doing that while they're busy punching the
crap out of each other all over the Earth he tries
to explain you need to stop doing this there's a
greater threat that we all have to band together
to fight that kind of happened during the Justice
League movie like Darkseid comes and they all have
to band together but like I said usually the only
time Black Adam gets involved like the reason why
it would be a Black Adam Justice League movie is
because it's magic related and speaking of Henry
Cavill coming back as Superman someone actually
made a funny trailer edit of Superman vs Black
Adam based on that recent Black Adam promo like
no one can stop me like oh no one except Superman
there's no one on this planet that can stop me
if you guys didn't know too Henry cavill's
actually been using the Rock's management
company for a lot of his business as an actor
that's why you see pictures of the two of them
together they are Bros now but like there's also
business on the side that they have together so
the main idea right now is that like the rock
is trying to get this black Adam versus Justice
League movie going in the future he is the best
chance that Henry Cavill has is coming back as
Superman the other funny thing I didn't mention
earlier too is if you notice in that Justice
League promo they didn't include footage of the
flash I think for obvious reasons just better let
that lay low till next year until they have to
Market that movie out of sight out of mind but
when it comes to actual DC EU flash I think Ezra
Miller is out no matter what like they'll release
the movie they're not going to take him out of
it or anything like that or rework the movie in
some big way and after the movie comes out he
will not come back as The Flash in any big DC
projects like they'll just let the character lay
dormant for a little while and then probably bring
in a recast version or bring in another flash
like Wally West I did a video a while ago about
this big 10-year plan the CEO of Warner Brothers
has because of all these mergers that have been
happening the last couple of years we'll see what
ends up happening the next couple of years but it
is cool to find out that the rock really wants
to get more Justice League stuff going in the
dceu I think of all the projects that are coming
out now between this and Shazam Fury of the Gods
those are like the best chance of like the DCEU
continuing as you know it right now even though
they probably are going to recast some of the
actors at some point some will stick around some
will be recast and then some will be Multiverse
versions if there's any of the big Easter eggs
you spotted in the trailer that I didn't talk
about in the video or any other big questions
about the future of Black Adam in the DCEU
just write it below in the comments my next
big video will be House of the Dragon episode 6.
you can click here for that I'll update the link
as soon as I post it and you can click here
for all my other house of the dragon videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!